you see this
this is the 2021 ford bronco this is the
first edition two-door sasquatch edition
this thing has been so much fun to drive
me and my sister did a road trip to
vegas and back this does have the v6
engine and it is surprisingly way more
powerful than i thought and we were
cruising around vegas and you would just
hit that gas and you know what you
freaking go i'm so hyped we are out here
in basically the middle of the desert
this is the el mirage dry lake bed you
can bring atvs out here and we brought
the bronco out to have a little fun
get in loser we're going for a ride
[Music]
dude that was freaking fast i think i
was going almost 80 which in theory like
doesn't seem like fast i don't drive
fast for me it's fast
[Music]
welcome to the interior
so this actually is kind of like a navy
blue color here they've got our little
bronco logo here i also like that there
is plenty of storage in the center
console lots of lots of lots of places
to put things
also something down here that you might
notice i'm actually going to turn the
car on real quick this right here is a
wireless charger
pretty cool the top of this also comes
off something that i have not attempted
yet i think i'm going to try maybe to do
it for this video but not in the middle
of this dusty desert the seats are also
kind of awesome because they flip down
so i'm able to store a lot of stuff so
for our trip to vegas i'll show you guys
what these look like flip down this
actually pulls right up just like so but
like magic that just pushes down for
more storage there are so many flies in
here coming along for the ride now
here's how we can switch all of our goat
modes it has a nice interior display it
does have carplay which is nice hook up
my phone do my maps like you normally
would this also has obviously some
built-in navigation
towing
not today
so my dad actually used to have a 1978
ford bronco and this picture right here
is so incredible this is actually me
sitting in this bicycle and that's my
mom driving and she even has a bronco
t-shirt on and i wish that she still had
this shirt i'm going to search
everywhere when i go back home to see if
i can find it but you can see my dad's
ford bronco in the background and now
here i am many many many many years
later testing out the 2021 and the cool
thing is this is the first edition and
they originally were only making 3 500
of these but they did end up
manufacturing about 7 000. obviously
this is the two-door they have a
four-door version which i know the
two-door is super cool but i think for
my lifestyle and amount of hoarding that
i do and people in and out of my car i
think i would probably get the four-door
if i was getting one just for the
practicality reasons but the two-door
definitely looks way cooler
it is such a nice day out and i thought
wow since i have this bronco i should
probably take the top off of it now i
did a little investigating and to take
the entire roof off it is a little bit
of a process you do need some tools but
it's honestly so easy just to take these
top two panels off but we're gonna do
that and ride around
and
get it i'm gonna start with the driver's
side there's four latches you just have
to flip these unhook this one
and that's it
this is like not even very heavy at all
and now we do the same thing on the
passenger side
so this wire i actually taped up here
because i put a dash cam in and this
isn't my car i didn't really want to be
able to like you know start removing
things to hide this wire so this is not
a part of
the bronco that's a justine add-on
whoa
[Music]
okay this looks great
i mean even without the back off
this is cool like i feel like i'm ready
to go cruise at the beach
oh man i am peak influencer now let's go
to the beach
[Music]
does anybody want to be our friend
well thank you guys so much for watching
i hope you enjoyed this video i just
wanted to show you guys this awesome
bronco and a huge thank you to ford for
letting us borrow this for the week i've
had the best time ever don't forget to
like comment subscribe hit the bell i'll
see you later
[Music]